[Música]
bien
amanecía en una fresca mañana de otoño
con los primeros rayos del sol partía a
su diaria tarea
de ayudante de jardinero
sus intensos y escasos doce años le
habían mostrado a veces incluso con
crueldad que parte del sustento propio y
de su familia dependían de esta diaria
tarea
llegado el mediodía
una rápida comida
y salía caminando a un colegio rural que
estaba cerca de su casa
en el aparte de la educación recibía
muchas veces el afecto y el
reconocimiento que tanto necesitaba
el mayor de tres hijos de una familia de
un papá casi siempre ausente
y así concluyendo la jornada de trabajo
en la mañana y estudio en la tarde
regresaba lentamente a su casa incluso
muchas veces como intentando estirar el
tiempo
sabía que al llegar le quedaba una tarea
entre otras tantas pendientes y era
colocar un poco de agua dentro de una
regadera de plástico y comenzar a rociar
el piso de tierra del sitio donde vivían
y luego por supuesto sin levantar tierra
barrerlo y todo esto bajo la atenta
mirada de su madre que cada tanto solía
recordar
recordad decía no importa si es de
tierra igual tiene que estar limpio
tránsito su adolescencia como obrero en
un viñedo
y al estar casi finalizando el colegio
secundario decidió que iba a probar
suerte cambiando de trabajo
para empezar a hacerlo en un criadero de
gallinas el día anterior a su partida el
capataz de la finca donde trabajaba se
le acercó y le dijo mira sé que mañana
te vas
y yo sé que eso sea alguien muy
inteligente pero pero quiero decirte
algo porque si realmente quieres
aprender y quieres progresar y quieres
ser alguien en la vida ahí hay dos cosas
que tienes que incorporar
la primera es tienes que descubrir en
los que están alrededor tuyo que pueden
enseñarte porque todos los hombres y
mujeres que te rodean pueden ser tus
maestros en algo y la segunda si
verdaderamente quieres progresar
es que tienes que aprender que poco es
siempre infinitamente mejor que nada
no era una vida de abundancia
sin embargo
el estudio se había transformado poco a
poco como en un sitio mágico un lugar a
donde entraba y un poco que las
carencias las historias los recuerdos
los fracasos los abandonos hasta el
tiempo mismo desaparecido
por eso no es de extrañar que una vez
que contra todo pronóstico terminó la
secundaria casi sin pensarlo mucho
decidió comenzar a estudiar en una
universidad
tenía que caminar un par de horas como
mínimo para cursar todos los días pero
estaba en una universidad
y todo parecía marchar no sé al ritmo de
algún proyecto alocado
pero un día no cualquiera este proyecto
pareció derrumbarse en un instante en el
profundo abismo del sinsentido
se encontraba caminando como diariamente
lo hacía para ir a cursar cuando pasó
por al lado de unos árboles prolijamente
cortados
casi el nacimiento del tronco en las
pegados a la raíz
al verlos
no pudo evitar pensar en su propia vida
un tremendo dolor un profundo e intenso
dolor se abatió sobre él
tan impactante tan fuerte que sólo atinó
va a sentarse al lado de los árboles y
ajeno totalmente al mundo ponerse a
llorar
y mientras lloraba
solo se le escuchaba decir porque a mí
porque a mí
en eso estaba
absorto de la realidad
cuando una voz interior los sorprendió
diciéndole
yo sé que caminas porque no tenés dinero
sé que caminas porque no puedes pagar un
colectivo
pero y si tuvieras dinero
y si tuvieras la plata para pagar el
colectivo sería tan hombre
de aún teniendo el dinero caminar igual
simplemente por mostrarle a la vida por
anticipado agradecimiento por todo lo
que te va a dar
no sé dijo balbuceando mientras lloraba
y casi sin darse cuenta se puso de pie y
termino contestando pero creo que lo voy
a intentar
a partir de ahí
aquel joven dejó de caminar
por necesidad económica y empezó a
caminar
para recordar su futura felicidad
cuando caminaba rumbo a la universidad
se imaginaba
en un cálido y confortable salón de
conferencias
sentado frente a él en cómodas butacas
un importante número de personas lo
escuchaban mientras él brindaba un tema
de su especialidad
al recrear esta historia es muy probable
que unos cuantos de nosotros
hayamos traído al presente algún momento
de nuestra vida alguna anécdota o algún
recuerdo que nos enseñó que no importa
si un piso es de tierra igual puede
limpiarse
o alguna enseñanza de algún maestro que
por suerte nos tocó en la vida que nos
dijo tenés que aprender de todos los que
están a tu alrededor porque todos pueden
ser tus maestros
o algo o alguien que en algún momento
nos indicó y nos hizo ver que poco es
siempre infinitamente mejor que nada
y saben por qué es esto
esto es así porque nuestra vida no son
las cosas que nos pasan la vida de cada
uno de nosotros mi vida no son las cosas
que pasan
son las historias que podemos construir
mientras transitamos por los eventos que
acontecen alrededor de nosotros
todos y cada uno de nosotros tenemos en
nuestro interior una tremenda y
fantástica máquina que construyen
nuestros tiempos y nuestros mundos todo
lo que recordamos
todo lo que pensamos todo lo que
sentimos la forma en que planificamos
depende de la historia que cada uno de
nosotros ha sido capaz de construir
y es tan tremendo el impacto que esto
genera que el mundo se transforma en una
representación tridimensional de mi
propio interior
pensemos si no si estoy triste si estoy
apenado
todos pierde color todo se vuelve gris
todo se vuelve frío
si estoy enamorado las luces se
encienden la realidad se llena de color
y hasta el clima es cálido
cuando algo me gusta el tiempo pasa a
una velocidad asombrosa
si estoy aburrido
esta charla se volvió insoportable
todos nosotros llevamos en nuestro
interior esta máquina y esta máquina es
tan maravillosa que no solamente
construye las historias en las que
sentimos pensamos planificábamos
logramos sino que sea una máquina que
además incluye la construcción de los
tiempos en donde esas historias se dan y
como las historias son tan distintas
esta máquina construye tiempos distintos
esto que parece difícil permítame un
ejemplo como para más o menos traducir
pensemos en la última hora antes de
haber venido acá o en la última hora que
hemos transitado juntos compartiendo
este fantástico evento
cada recuerdo que tengamos en donde hay
una sucesión de elementos primero una
cosa luego otra luego otra luego otra es
una historia que estamos construyendo en
un tiempo lineal
sin embargo perfectamente puede haber
habido un montones de momentos montones
de instantes en donde en un mismo
instante hemos recreado múltiples
vivencias múltiples pensamientos ahí no
se trata de un tiempo lineal y sucesivo
se trata de que en un mismo instante hay
múltiples tiempos es decir esta máquina
que todos transportamos construye
nuestras historias construyen nuestros
mundos y construye nuestros tiempos
pero no cuando todo viene bien y pero
pero justamente hay un dato sencillo
simple pero muy importante que tenemos
que tener en cuenta y es que esta
fantástica máquina siempre trabaja con
la última versión que hemos construido
del mundo y del tiempo
esto no puedo decir ah qué fantástico
porque está siempre actualizado como si
fuese un programa o algo que se
actualiza automáticamente si es verdad
pero el problema de esto es que si
nosotros no estamos al timón de nuestra
máquina nuestra máquina sigue repitiendo
el mismo modelo mientras pasa el tiempo
y ese mismo modelo que vamos repitiendo
terminamos volviéndonos adictos a él
y si no como se entiende que tantas
veces recreamos la misma obra de teatro
con diferentes actores en lo que es la
dramatización de nuestra vida
cómo es posible que sabiendo que no
debemos cometer determinados errores o
tener determinadas cosas que modificar
las sigo repitiendo
y esto sucede porque cuando no
actualizamos cuando no nos ponemos al
timón nosotros de la máquina la máquina
sigue repitiendo la última versión
nuestro interior neuroquímico se
acostumbra y luego se vuelve adicto
y acá no hay inteligencia que valga
entonces
si esto es así la pregunta podría ser
perfectamente como hacemos
para ponernos al timón de nuestra
máquina miren las respuestas que tengo
para dar a esa pregunta son bastante
sencillas y evidentes pero permítanme
que aunque sea un repaso entre todos
podamos hacerlo
si es una máquina no es acaso legítimo
que la primera pregunta que me formule
sea qué tipo de combustible le doy
ninguno de todos nosotros creo que
utiliza un combustible indebido en su
auto
sin embargo nosotros consumimos en
general azúcar harinas refinadas o sea
todo lo más adictivo para después querer
que nuestra máquina no sea adictiva
no comemos por demanda comemos por
horario o sea que no utilizamos la
alimentación para poder activar un
montón de grupos celulares que están
distribuidos en todo nuestro interior y
que conforman esta maquinaria porque
también les quiero contar algo muy
importante esta máquina de la que
estamos hablando no habita en nuestro
cerebro
en nuestro interior hay montones de
grupos celulares distribuidos que tienen
que ser activados sincronizados y
coordinados y ahí sí es cierto por un
gran tablero de comando que está acá
detrás del lóbulo frontal si seguimos en
esto de apropiarnos de nuestra máquina
que fue lo que me dijo podemos ver de
nuevo y decir bueno qué más puedo hacer
por ejemplo podrías aprender a relajarte
un poco antes de irte a dormir digo
porque si no después en la noche seguir
trabajando y te levantas a la mañana más
cansado de lo que te acostaste o por
ejemplo podré poner en mi agenda semanal
cotidiana un poco de una caminata un
hobby pero no un deporte solamente para
ser campeón mundial de algo porque
empiezo a andar en bicicleta de la
semana quiero ser campeón mundial
porque como estoy tan adicto a la
adrenalina cualquier cosa que quiero
colocar para disfrutar se tiñe de
adrenalina y luego me vuelve loco y lo
que era un partidito de domingo es la
copa mundial intergaláctica
se entendió y además lo tengo que
publicar porque no alcanza con yo
saberlo
si esa fue gratis no estaba en el
libreto si preguntan eso
esto significa tengo que ponerme y
comprarme algún aparato que muestre los
kilómetros los segundos las pulgadas y
si esta vez tarde no sé cuánto la semana
que viene mucho menos posición a no
publicar nada y si no público no soy
qué loco no
retomemos perdón entonces y si me
alimento un poquito mejor y se aprendo a
relajarme para descansar y si hago
alguna actividad física amándola
disfrutándola y si hago algo de
jardinería y si estudio algún idioma o
si ejecutó algún instrumento musical
pero no para ser campeón mundial de nada
o si estudio de algo que no es mi
materia para no estar leyendo siempre
más de lo mismo
y entonces qué voy a hacer con eso voy a
nutrir voy a expandir cuando uno le dice
estas cosas a la gente porque a diario
uno recibe consultas de qué hago para
hacer personas digamos este entonces la
gente aún no mire qué lindo si no me
siento que poquito como sé que no te
pague la consulta no entonces
este ahora si es como lindo pero poco
por decirlo ahora discúlpenme
quien dijo que poco es poco
hace 10 minutos atrás estábamos todos de
acuerdo que pocos infinitamente mejor
que nada y ahora resulta que eso es poco
y por eso no alcanza
hagan poco amén poco pero amén
amén lo que hacen aunque parezca poco
y sepan que cuando están haciendo todos
estos pedacitos de poco
se están convirtiendo en la mejor
versión en la más evolucionada versión
de cada uno de ustedes mismos
no será que poco es uno de esos montones
de términos que utilizamos cuando
queremos un poco dejar así como
tapaditos que estamos adictos a nuestra
manera de ser y no sabemos cómo dejar de
serlo no será que poco es una de esas
palabras que usamos cada tanto entre
otras muchas para decir mira me llene de
datos que no sé cómo utilizar
yo sé que son capaz de hacer poco
pero el proceso de desintoxicación
siempre siempre es difícil
hoy
al igual que hace ya unos cuantos años
en aquellas caminatas hacia la
universidad
nos volvemos a encontrar
en este cálido y confortable salón de
conferencias
hoy
ustedes y yo
estamos nuevamente reunidos
y por esa causalidad que siempre emerge
cuando uno construye tiempos
estamos reunidos tratando de compartir y
de aprender cómo utilizar esta
maravillosa máquina que todos
transportamos y pasar a poseerla
y por este reencuentro
y por este tiempo
permítanme decirles a todos y cada uno
de ustedes en particular a cada uno de
ustedes
muchas gracias por haberme acompañado en
aquel entonces
muchas muchas gracias por haberme
acompañado desde siempre muy amables
[Aplausos]